there are now more and more calls for
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg to step
down as a result of just scandal after
scandal involving the social networking
website and one of the latest crises is
truly disgusting in a world of
right-wing rabbit holes and discrediting
techniques is the thinly veiled
anti-semitic trope of blaming things
connecting people criticizing movements
that they don't like by connecting them
to George Soros we know about this
George Soros is the left-wing
billionaire philanthropist who happens
to be Jewish Soros has become attached
to countless conspiracy theories which
blur the line between sort of unhinged
right-wing political conspiracies and
just straight-up anti-semitic conspiracy
theories and often times those lines are
very very blurred recently Soros
received a pipe bomb in the mail you
might remember and the recesses of the
internet crawling with the ideas about
Soros came up with the idea that Soros
is in cahoots with Jews to send him
false flag fake pipe bombs so that Jews
can generate pity for themselves right
that was one idea that was floated after
the pipe bomb but bigger picture there's
this idea that Jews are behind the
scenes fomenting social unrest for their
own gain the idea that Jews are this
other working to subvert public and
private resources for their gain and
this stuff has a really long toxic
history which relates to the idea of
Jews as a threat which underpinned
countless anti-jewish movements over the
last several hundred years example
Timothy McVeigh the 1996 Oklahoma City
bomber believed that Jews were
participating in the civil rights era in
support of the rights of black people as
a way to take white people out of power
not because they wanted equal rights for
black people but to create a power
vacuum where Jews would actually be able
to take over so I think you kind of get
it at this point you pin stuff on Soros
that's part of a very well
known anti-semitic playbook of
conspiracy theories about Jews what's
the news and what does this have to do
with Facebook well we've now learned
that Facebook hired a PR firm to try to
discredit their critics which ended up
claiming that the critics of Facebook
were agents of or funded by George Soros
now I know you'll say hold on a second
David Mark Zuckerberg is Jewish and the
CEO of Facebook Sheryl Sandberg is
Jewish why would they do something
anti-semitic well of course number one
we have no idea whether Zuckerberg and
Sandberg were personally involved in
hiring this firm or okaying the George
Soros approach but secondly what does it
matter if they're Jewish as Trump has
shown us you can both have Jewish family
and be signaling to anti-semites that
you're their guy at the same time those
two things can happen at the same time
and reporters Pat have been coming
forward saying that when they've been
working on articles about Facebook they
will talk to their contacts at this PR
agency and that the people at the PR
agency keep reminding them hey listen
these are soros tactics and it would be
really important for you to make that
clear this is like what Soros does and
this is truly disgusting and my only
question at this point Pat is can suck
ur bird survive this because the calls
for him to resign or growing that'll be
terrible for Facebook's shareholders but
they're not really my number one concern
I don't even know what the future of
Facebook is at this point because
there's nothing permanent if we know
anything on the Internet
myspace seemed insurmountable at one
point and it's gone Facebook is really
in trouble here yeah well it seems that
Zuckerberg survives the last few
controversies over data misuse so maybe
he will be able to survive this one too
he pointed out my space myspace was only
around for a few years though whereas
Facebook is now been around for over a
decade and they still have quite a lot
of users so I think they can survive a
contributors controversy like this one -
fair point they also make a lot more
money than myspace every day so it's not
the same situation but this is
absolutely disgusting and if you're
canceling your Facebook account over
this the data breach whatever
let me know I want to hear from you I'm
really excited to tell you about one of
today's sponsors Fair Indigo com you've
heard me talk about them before they are
offering 15% off your first order only
when you use promo code Pakman at
checkout most people in our audience
know that workers rights abuses
pollution these are massive issues in
the garment industry and we've covered
it before fair indigo calm is a clothing
company that has taken a stand on these
issues they make clothing from premium
alpaca and ultra high quality organic
pima cotton which is the softest and
longest lasting cotton on earth and it's
grown by small-scale farmers without any
pesticides everything is manufactured in
eco-friendly artisan workshops in Lima
Peru that pay their workers fair living
wages if you're watching on YouTube
right now I am wearing the alpaca
baseball sweater and I love it get
compliments everywhere I go unfair
indigo you'll find everything from men's
short and long sleeve t-shirts polo
sweaters hoodies even belts and wallets
made from recycled materials to women's
tops pants dresses and scarves you
should have no trouble finding something
that will fit your style and beyond
workers rights and sustainability fair
Indigo's specialty is extreme quality
everything they sell is meant to last
you a lifetime click the link under this
video shipping is always free on orders
over $75 and you'll save 15% when you
use the promo code PA que ma n at
checkout